wednesday edition pft live pftpm
hiatus style plenty of things to discuss
in the nfl even though training camps
still aren't open i saw a tweet earlier
today of ben roethlisberger showing up
not latrobe in pittsburgh remember
they're not going back to st
vincent college this year the nfl
wouldn't allow it but the cowboys
and the steelers and the buccaneers
opening up this week next week everyone
else there will be more
and more news but even with the vast
majority of the nfl still in hibernation
there's plenty of news and let's begin
with tom brady the buccaneers
quarterback yesterday
at the white house a couple of funny
lines couple of jokes i'm not going to
talk about that though we've already
written about it and there really isn't
much more to say
other than he may need to hire a
slightly better team
of writers the jokes were good not great
i'd give him maybe a 7.5 out of 10
could have done better should have
farmed that out to someone other than
whoever he farmed it out
too that said he had a a town hall
recently with jim gray it looks more
like a fireside
chat with a crappy gas log over his
shoulder
a lot of topics that brady discussed
during that now that town hall goes live
later today i believe
but some things that we've written about
at pft
uh first of all on the topic of who the
unnamed mother effer was remember the
comment from the shop
a few weeks back that there was a team
that was interested and
backed out late in the 2020 free agency
process and
brady's reaction was you're sticking
with that mother bleeper
brady says that that's something he uses
for private motivation he's not going to
make it public
never mind the fact that he's already
made it public
he's stopping short of making the names
involved
public but he says they know who they
are and there's been so much speculation
about who it is and i knew brady was
never
going to actually address it i'm glad he
was asked the question
because i thought there was a chance
that he ultimately would never be
so we now know that he knows and the
team knows
and the mother bleeper knows and brady's
not going to say anything more about it
as we expected another thing brady
discusses
in that session with jim gray the
possibility of playing beyond the age of
45. now
earlier this week there were quotes from
alex guerrero
tom brady's personal trainer tb12
that brady's got two more seasons brady
himself has said i've got two more
seasons but brady
made it clear that once he gets to that
point once he finishes
the season during which he chan he he
will turn
45 and he'll be 44 as of august 3 this
year so
my math skills good enough to tell me
that next year at this time he'll be
turning 45
into that season supposedly end of his
career he says he'll
evaluate where he is at that point and
make a decision but if he can still play
at a championship level and it fits with
his overall life obligations
he could keep playing and we can't rule
out
frankly the possibility of brady
going somewhere else after
the 2022 season you can't rule it out he
said before i've got two years on my
contract with the buccaneers i'm going
to play two more years
he talked about going back to foxboro
and he said this
is probably the last time i'll play
there well it's definitely the last time
unless you're going to change teams
because the buccaneers won't be back
there for several more years
so yeah it's it's definitely the last
time he's gonna play in foxboro
unless after the 2022 season tom brady
decides to
pick another spot and try to win a super
bowl with
a third franchise which would not be
surprising if he pulled it off but it
would make his
historic career even more historic and
likely unmatchable by anyone for however
long the nfl happens
to hang around so don't be surprised if
he keeps playing
beyond 2022 and i'll add to that don't
be stunned
if at the end of the day he decides
maybe i'll give
another team a spin maybe there's
another team out there that will be more
stacked
and clearly in need of him to come in
there
and shake things up and do what he
managed to do last year in his first
season with the buccaneers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports